the Joe Rogan experience for them
actually no this is for we're gonna play
big man yeah yeah we want to do this
this is for them to George florid
because you know his nickname was big
Floyd or big right yeah I didn't
obviously didn't know well not all the
lyrics line up but it does it's an
homage to a great man who who passed
originally and it just feels apropos to
do it now yeah yeah cool
[Music]
oh man that they steal buckets
they're playing white faces and playing
great start
II took old cane
[Music]
every man baby
happy that he's gone
[Music]
there was a trimming pull and they came
far and wide to the few when a people
show they were broke in will they let
down
baby that he's gone
[Music]
bones buried yeah bones buried deep
bones I won't shake my lady to sleep and
he looks down oh he looks up he was a
good man that was enough
[Music]
[Applause]